alors je vous pose est maintenant une
dernière question est-ce que vous
éteignez la lumière j'ai une question
simple gilles ménage question très
simple vous êtes un ou services de
l'établé fait l'ena avait été dans les
cabinets préfectoraux est ce que
finalement maintenant avec le recul
puisque publier des livres pour en
parler
est ce que vous regrettez pas excusé pas
un peu honte d'avoir fait tout ça
finalement nombre je pense vous êtes un
ange non je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que d'abord j'ai qualifie pas
comme vous les qualifiés est ce que je
peux dire c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'une
décision a été prise
j'ai toujours fait un papier écrit j'ai
toujours demandé d instruction je suis
instructions je ne pense vraiment pas
avoir franchi la ligne jaune
on se bat je veux pas vous chargez
m'enfin papon aussi dit moi je ne
faisait qu'obéir aux ordres
quand on est fonctionnaire en des temps
mais quand on est fonctionnaire on peut
le dire j'ai obéi aux ordres il bien non
non quel effet il faut savoir désobéir
c'est ce que tout le monde a dit à papon
d'air non vous auriez dû désormais on
n'était pas du tout dans cette
configuration la joue là c'est pas moins
grave
bon lorsque ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est le fond de ma réponse
un fonctionnaire si vous voulez on peut
pas prendre d'initiatives en tout cas
moi c'est ma philosophie
sans être totalement en harmonie avec le
pouvoir politique
or il se trouve que dans son pays dans
ce pays à taden politique parce que ça
les arrange parce qu'ils ont des soucis
de carrière sont parfois amnésique
parfois renégats et ça devient un peu
facile de dire bah voilà nous
on n'était pas au courant on savait pas
de taper le lampiste alors d'élite
non moi j'ai pas après tout je trouve
que j'ai eu beaucoup de satisfactions à
faire ce métier il ya depuis quelques
années c'est vrai beaucoup
d'inconvénients
je pense que dans la vie il faut savoir
accepter les inconvénients c'est
davantage bien à lui merci c'est tout
phil belhaj merci louis ce bijou salut
vous y allez mais bon je vous souhaite
tout champion mais moi